you know
um
okay
okay
um
um
thank you
it's always
wow
yeah i see both of them they're ready
is
everybody
yes
okay
two minute warning to press briefing two
minute warning to press briefing thank
you
yes
is
[Music]
um
exactly that's how it is
[Music]
good afternoon
okay um today we have joining us our nec
director brian diese i was going to give
some brief opening remarks i'll take
some questions and then we'll do a
briefing from there take it away all
right
hello everybody hello it's good to be
here today
all right
enthusiasm i like that
um
so i just wanted to uh spend a couple of
minutes on uh providing some context on
where we are in the economic recovery um
and also use some charts should be
really fun
um
the president uh
the president released a statement
earlier today
saying that our economy our economic
recovery has two components getting
americans back to work
and getting prices in supply chains back
to normal
and so i want to provide a little bit of
context on
our perspective on that issue
so uh at first today we learned that the
number of americans filing for
unemployment insurance fell to its
lowest level since 1969.
and i will as i think i have done every
time i've come to this podium reinforced
that every time we look at data like
this one week even one month can be
volatile so we look at the averages and
trends but if you look at the first
slide here you'll see that the trend
underscores
that the four week moving average for
initial ui claims is now down by about
75
since the beginning of the year
and another way to think about that is
that at the beginning of this year there
were 18 million americans
who were collecting unemployment
benefits
and today we learned that now that that
number has fallen to fewer than 2
million so in addition to that
consistent trend we're also seeing a
reduction in 16 million americans who
were previously relying on government
benefits that have now transitioned off
of it
we also learned last week that the
unemployment rate fell to 4.2 percent
which is again the fastest year to get a
decline in the unemployment rate on
record um and in this uh second chart
you see
uh there we are
uh this the second chart you see that
that is not only the fastest decline but
it's also very significantly uh
accelerated from what was projected at
the beginning of this year so uh the um
the i guess ma what color is that that
light brown line
the brown line the light brown line
shows the uh the uh projections from the
beginning of this year prior to the
passage of the american rescue plan
which showed that our it would be
projected to take our economy until uh
the end of 2024 to get to an
unemployment rate of about 4.2 percent
uh and now we have reached that in the
fourth quarter of 2021 uh which
underscores both the uh the significance
of the american rescue plan and helping
drive a strong labor market recovery but
also just the um the benefit for the
american people of reaching that point
um i would just note as well um in in
terms of uh labor market strength that
we have also seen encouraging signs in
labor force participation uh because uh
when the unemployment comes the rate
comes down it can be because people are
joining the labor force or coming out
and we saw that the the prime age
employment
population ratio which the the metric of
uh that economists generally look at
increased by five tenths of a percent
last month and we've now recovered
nearly 85 percent of our uh pandemic
drop in
um
in that metric
so we've seen very strong labor mark
developments and that those labor market
developments are coupled by strong
developments in overall uh economic
growth and in household income and uh
demand
and so that puts us in a position where
today real household income
is higher than before the pandemic so
real household income for the typical
american family is 350 a month higher
now than before the pandemic in real
terms accounting for price increases
accounting for inflation and so that
strength that strength of the labor
market that strength of household
balance sheets that strength of economic
growth positions us uniquely well to
deal with the challenges that we face of
prices and supply chain issues in fact
uniquely among uh industrialized
countries we are the only country that
has seen gdp now recover from its
pre-pandemic levels has seen household
income recover from its
pandemic levels so that positions us
uniquely well um and so on that note we
are um as you all know very focused on
addressing the issue of prices and
supply chain uh bottlenecks uh head on
uh uh from that position of strength
tomorrow we will get data on consumer
prices for november
and
i'm not going to attempt to predict what
those data are outside forecasters
expect those data to continue to show
price increases at to remain at elevated
levels um but i want to provide a little
bit of context on that uh front as well
the first is that that data is by
definition backward looking and so it
won't capture some recent price
movements
particularly in the area of energy
and so for example uh
prices of gas at the gas pump are now
down nationally um they're down about
nine cents but to get put some context
on that this next chart over here this
shows the uh the inflation-adjusted real
price of gas at the pump
over the last
10 years and what it shows is that on
average
uh over the last uh uh 10 years and in
fact this is true over the last 20 years
the average price at the pump for a
gallon of gas has been about three
dollars and 13 cents in real terms
inflation adjusted and so today uh 20
states now have pump prices that are
below that 20-year average um and as uh
the as prices come down nationally um
over the next couple of weeks as we
expect and hope that they will
we hope to see more states uh falling
into that category um
those price reductions will not be
reflected in in the data for uh uh
november
um in addition this week we've seen
natural gas prices fall they're now down
25 percent from their average in
november
and that is uh uh that is good news
particularly looking into the winter
home heating season i know several of
you reported on and we're focused on uh
natural gas price increases earlier this
fall uh portending potentially big
increases in uh in heating costs over
the winter the very dramatic decline in
natural gas prices over the course of
the last couple of weeks have changed
that outlook uh
quite uh meaningfully um so these
declines uh are delivering most
importantly some some benefit to uh
consumers uh and some benefits because
consumers on a go forward basis uh that
won't be reflected uh in that data
secondly we've seen some near movements
on other commodity prices uh over the
course of the last couple of weeks we've
seen shipping costs uh to move a
container from asia to the united states
come down by about 25
uh over the course last couple of weeks
the price of wheat the price of pork um
has come down and importantly used cars
as well i know many of you have seen and
tracked in some of the recent
price data that used cars have played an
outsize influence there's been
challenges in the used car market
including uh relating to uh reflecting
the fact that rental car companies sold
off their fleets and we're buying back
um we anticipate that uh some of the
recent decline in used car prices at the
wholesale level uh indicates that we
would may see prices decline there as
well again that won't be reflected in uh
in backward looking data from tomorrow
and lastly
the consensus estimates of outside
experts continue to
forecast and project that price
increases will moderate uh going into
2022 um the blue chip consensus for core
pce inflation for example and by the
fourth quarter of next year is down to
uh 2.2
um
uh
uh for example um so yeah so that's i
think important context for all of you
in thinking about um the uh the data uh
releases but most importantly from our
perspective it is a reason to redouble
our efforts to focus on both the
immediate term and the medium-term steps
that we can take to try to address
prices and bring down costs for
families that's what we're focused on
with respect to our supply chain work uh
our energy price work and and of course
in moving the bill back better uh act uh
which will do more than any piece of
legislation in modern american history
to reduce costs for families so with
that
i will open the floor thank you jen and
brian thank you for being here um
jumping off right there and build back
better as you anticipate and wait for
this new data tomorrow and i think
there's also going to be a new cost
estimate of buildback that are requested
by republicans how concerned is the
white house that it will complicate your
efforts to win over those moderate
democrats like joe manchin
well we are quite confident
that if the
question is
what can we do to address the costs that
are most pressing to american families
that that if that is the debate and that
is the discussion
then um the case for the build back
better act um is
only gets stronger
and that we are
building momentum around uh that set of
arguments
if you step back and you think about a
typical family's budget
what they have to spend on expenses in a
typical month
about 60 percent of those costs fall
into
housing
health care
prescription drugs
child care and transportation that's
what you know the bulk of a family's
budget uh yeah is made up of and on each
of those areas the legislation that the
president has prioritized and is moving
through congress would address and
reduce those costs and so i think that
if um if if that's the debate and that's
the question how can we address those
costs that families are facing again the
buildback better act will do more to
lower costs than any piece of
legislation in modern american history
and so we feel um quite
you know enthusiastic about being able
to make that case well one quick follow
on inflation fed chair jerome powell
said that transitory is no longer the
right way to describe inflation he said
it now appears that factors pushing
inflation upward will linger well into
next year given that do you believe that
this inflation is now more entrenched
and not transitory
what we what we what we believe is that
price increases elevated the level that
we're seeing um
hit american families in their pocket
books and we need to do everything that
we can to
address those directly
we also believe that the strength of our
economic recovery the strength of our
labor market and the strength of wage
increases and the steps that we've taken
to try to provide some relief to
american families position our economy
and american households uniquely well to
address what is a global issue around
price increases in the context of supply
chains in other
will these increase prices last through
next year
well i i am not going to get into uh the
prediction business other than to say
and i'll echo what i what i uh what i
noted at the beginning is that most
outside independent forecasters continue
to see increases moderating and
moderating meaningfully over the course
of next year
along the same line the president did
try to set expectations in his statement
today saying he expects inflation
numbers to stay high to stay high but
that doesn't reflect the reality so
would you expect the reports will
actually reflect this
well i would just point to some of the
real world you know uh real-world data
that we're seeing which is that we've
seen uh we've seen gas prices come back
we've seen natural gas prices come down
um we've seen uh we've seen real
progress in unsticking some of the
supply chain uh bottlenecks uh that uh
that have been that persisted uh in uh
in our economy i was you know noting on
supply chains that there's actually now
some reporting that the principal
concern is on the back end of uh the
holiday season uh too much excess
inventory people have uh uh over ordered
and so uh so certainly these are not you
know these are these are things that
don't work themselves out overnight um
and and we
i will go back to what i've said at the
beginning of this we never over index on
any one piece of data on or any one uh
uh data release um but we you know we're
going to stay focused on what we can do
to try to address these prices in the
immediate term
thank you um
just talking about sort of gas prices
coming down uh right uh a group of uh
bipartisan lawmakers uh six of them from
texas as you're probably aware it's a
letter to president biden
about not reinstituting a ban on uh u.s
oil exports
what is the position of the white house
on that uh considering the letter was
sent
explicitly saying that the white house
is considering a move to that effect
it's not an issue that we're currently
focused on
the president
in our focus on energy markets has made
clear to the team that all options
should be on the table to try to address
challenges in the market and bring
relief to american consumers that's
certainly the approach that we have
taken to date in our international
engagements our diplomatic engagements
and actions we've taken including the uh
exchange and sale from the strategic
petroleum reserve that the president
announced about ten days ago uh so we
will continue to work on those issues we
continue to work with states and
localities to make sure that they have
the uh support that they need but that
that specific issue is not one that
we're currently focused on
sorry just a quick uh
um in terms of sort of your overall um
you know
economic growth sort of forecasts from
the white house and given the fact that
the the omicron variant is spreading uh
rapidly uh some economists have started
uh factoring in a surface slowdown in
demand and you know for services and
hiring in general uh what are some of
your expectations just
over the next few quarters uh in terms
of overall economic growth in the us
well
we like others are obviously tracking
very closely the questions raised by the
uh the omicron variant uh and
are um waiting and watching the
information and as we receive it with uh
and with the understanding that we need
to know more but we are learning some
we've seen some encouraging
data coming out recently
but it's something that we will continue
to monitor closely and study closely in
terms of you know current uh growth uh
currently um all indications are that
the economy in the fourth quarter
continues to grow robustly um and uh we
certainly expect that uh to uh to
continue and and our focus is on how we
can maintain the strength of the overall
economic recovery the strength of the
labor market recovery while also
addressing head on these uh these price
challenges uh uh and the supply chain
bottlenecks and to be very clear that
the risk
exists that price increases become
entrenched in the long term that's
something that would be a real problem
for the economy we are working
in in looking forward and don't see that
um
in the current environment but are you
know focused on the steps that we can
take to drive that kind of robust
recovery going forward thank you jen
thank you brian just a quick follow-up
and build that better and then one on
unemployment given how
involved you are with negotiations what
is the most viable timeline right now
for passing it and it's before christmas
still realistic
so
um we want to move as quickly as
possible uh and we
are working very closely with senator
schumer and the and the entire uh caucus
on uh facilitating that outcome and uh
senator schumer has
indicated his uh uh his intention his
timeline and we're both supportive of
that and believe that that's uh uh
that's right and viable we want to move
as quickly as possible here we think
that that the outstanding issues are um
getting worked through uh in the process
we're making a lot of progress um so uh
so we are we want to move as quick as
possible and we believe there's a reason
why we can
and in terms of unemployment the system
now and i think we referenced this
earlier doesn't account for big workers
and self-employed who were on uninsured
unemployment insurance but then they ran
out um if they were pandemic related so
is there any way you're tracking the
number of those people who might not be
included in the numbers but might still
be struggling and is there anything that
you can do
to help them
so
the uh there's sort of uh two two uh two
elements of that question the first is
that um there were people who were
previously receiving unemployment
insurance uh are no longer receiving
unemployment insurance are obviously not
reflected in the ui claims and these
reflect the people who are receiving
government assistance and that has come
down dramatically as i said from 18
million to less than 2 million within
that category people who were on
unemployment insurance and
and then and then and then come off
unemployment insurance the way to track
that data is really to look at the labor
force data because um those people could
either be in the labor force actively
looking for a job or they could be
employed or they could end up out of the
labor force and so one of the things
from an economic point of view one of
the concerns that you have is to track
the labor force participation because if
people come off of unemployment but they
leave the labor force entirely then
that's a that's an outcome that you you
you want you hope to avoid so that one
of the positive indications in our
current labor market is that what we're
seeing is even as the number of people
receiving unemployment insurance has
come down dramatically labor force
participation has stayed steady and
started to tick up which suggests that
people are coming back into the labor
market finding jobs in many cases or are
actively looking for jobs but that's the
sort of best proxy to get at what i
think you're trying to refer to thank
you um friend some of the critics
administration's critics have said the
last few months as these reports come
out and show inflation is rising
that the administration highlighting the
bright spots like unemployment is
glossing over the reality that people
are paying more for food and things
basic necessities um and a lot of people
who are impacted the most are the
poorest or they're on fixed incomes they
might not be moved by an unemployment
statistic so what's your message to
those people especially getting closer
to the midterms
yeah absolutely and and just to be very
clear that the
uh
the issue of you know increased prices
hits people in very practical ways in
their lives and uh no one likes to pay
more at the gas pump nobody likes to pay
more at the grocery store and for people
who are
you know a lower income it could be it
can be tough i think my the message is
that um
employment and our labor market are
really important uh ways in which people
can seek and find economic opportunity
and prosperity and the fact that wages
are increasing the most
for people in the bottom 40 percent of
the income distribution is something
that hasn't happened in our economy and
sometimes is really positive because of
what it means is that there are more job
opportunities and job opportunities at
higher wages for people uh to move into
that's point one point two is that in
terms of household income and their
balance sheets
if you look at the bottom uh 25 or the
bottom 40 of households and you look at
both the increase in wages that people
have received and the the benefits that
people have received because in the
american rescue plan for example we
passed a child tax credit that is now
going to families on a monthly basis we
provided checks to people in there
and you look in the aggregate household
income for those people in the lower
ends of the income spectrum is actually
higher today on a monthly basis even
when you take into account increased
inflation so that's not true for every
person and then and every individual has
a challenges and we um we want to speak
to all of those but in terms of overall
economically speaking
because of the strength of the the
economic recovery the strength of the
labor market and the support that we've
provided over the course of the year
people are better positioned today to
deal with these challenges which are
real and which are tough and which is
why we're focused every day on what we
can do to try to alleviate them does the
administration see uh inflation as a
driving need to extend the child tax
credit
uh the our uh our our our view is that
the child tax credit is a uh you know a
really important basic support for
families and that we uh we we should
extend it and we should extend it
because it's doing what we um hoped it
would do
which is dramatically reduce child
poverty in america dramatically reduce
poverty in america and give
families some breathing room
in a very strong but uncertain recovery
so certainly it's the president's
position that um we should do that and
we can do that i would i would just
underscore we can do that as part of
buildback better in a way that is
fiscally responsible fully paid for
won't even add to any inflation air
pressures in the economy heather yes
thanks um brian can you give us any
timing when the president may name
additional fed nominees is that promised
drawing to a close could we see
something next week
i cannot
[Music]
josh
you uh alluded to the forecast for
tomorrow's number uh you know i know you
didn't want to name any so allow me
great uh 6.8
is our median estimate year over year
that's higher
than last time last month which is 6.2
the month of our month figure is point
seven point nines in other words they're
sort of showing different things your
beer is getting worse months of our
month getting better my question for you
is where are we do you think in the art
of inflation right now you reference
forecast bringing it down by q4 do you
think the wave is cresting when you talk
about backward-looking data do you think
the inflation is leveling off the data
aren't just capturing it or do you think
it's going to get worse before it gets
better
so
uh
a couple of points uh first i'm not
going to try to predict or project um
your your projection is a
aggregated estimate of a lot of people
have thought about this and i'm not
gonna get into the projection game we
obviously do our own um
uh
estimates uh the second is you raise an
important point i think this is good
context for in in you know in
anticipation of it which is because of
the what we have seen over the course of
the last 12 months or 11 months the
year-over-year headline uh number um
will be elevated compared to you know
historic uh levels under any
circumstances that's baked in um and
that's largely a function well that is
100 a function of everything that
happened
uh starting before november
uh of this year uh so in in a sense the
that year over year um
uh is
it should be taken with that context um
in terms of your question about you know
the timing i think that we are in a
place where we are seeing
some of the
uh when you look at one of the
underlying uh issues that are driving
those price pressures we're seeing some
some movement that is notable you know
as i've spoken about on energy um with
respect to the supply chains and our um
our our focus is on look in tracking
that across time because we think that
that will be what will end up flowing
through to affect those um uh those
numbers across time this is not you know
i i would not try to project on a you
know week or month by month basis
because this because these numbers move
around you know i mentioned used car
prices and a lot of people focus on
what's happening at the wholesale uh
markets uh uh when dealers are buying
used cars because that is really an
indication of where the prices are going
but that could take you know a month or
two to uh to filter through into data so
in each of these cases there are
specific elements we'll continue to look
closely at them but i think you have
seen you are seeing in some important
areas um some movement that is critical
do you think the wave is pressing or is
it too soon to say
you know we will we'll just we're going
to continue to focus on what we can do
uh to advance this recovery uh and
advance this recovery in a way where
you know typical households continue to
have some of that breathing room and
more americans are able to take
advantage of a job market where there
are you know historic opportunities out
there
phil
thanks brad two quick ones you know one
of the concerns last month beyond the
top line numbers was that perhaps it was
broadening out a little bit i'm thinking
particularly not just pandemic driven uh
price increases but maybe rent uh being
one specifically have you guys seen
anything in that side of things not
driven by the pandemics that has raised
concerns as you've looked at the data
well i'm glad you raised uh this issue
and around housing and and shelter
prices uh shelter being you know either
rent or
or homes
because i think it connects to a point
that that christian you raised which is
um
we have for years in this country had a
um a problem of inadequate housing
supply
of single-family homes to buy uh and
of of of houses to rent um it is a
decades uh
in the making
of under investment in affordable supply
particularly in areas of the country
where there is the most economic
opportunity and so it's a persistent
challenge of people wanting to move to
you know a different part of the country
where they might have a job opportunity
and are are costed out of that because
of housing
the answer to that problem
is to make a historic investment in
increasing the supply of affordable
housing in america
that is the real answer to that question
and the sooner that we do that the
sooner that we initiate that process the
sooner that we are going to actually
address that underlying challenge
and so some of the price increases that
are are already baked in and will uh
flow through to this uh to uh to these
numbers we know that everyone should
anticipate that but the real policy
question it goes to why build back
better is so important is are we going
to actually take some steps to finally
address that issue so that we can say to
the american people that looking forward
they can actually expect some real
relief the housing investments in the
buildback better plan are directed
exactly to to that issue how do we build
the kind of housing supply that the
typical people need across the country
in urban suburban and in rural areas and
so um that is it that's that is a real
present issue one that will continue to
be with us but hopefully if we can get
this bill done we'll actually have the
tools in place to start to show people
some real progress from a broader
perspective do you guys view it inside
your team as
an acceptable trade-off if prices are
high for a shorter duration a shorter
period of time
perhaps because of some of the
demand-driven
elements of arp
so long as you've been able to achieve
some of the uh
some of the data positive data you've
been laying out over the course of this
day and the white house has been talking
about for the last several months this
is a trade-off that's acceptable so long
as those price increases don't last or
become entrenched
um well i would start we were uh
we're uh humble enough to not uh suggest
that we we could control all the levers
of the macro economy and uh we're in a
complicated uncertain global environment
and number one number two i think that
uh um our view and and i think borne out
by what you're seeing internationally is
that uh the challenges of um supply
chains of price increases of uh of of
the issues of labor supply are
persistent across industrialized
countries but what's unique about the
united states right now is the strength
of our economic growth the strength of
our labor market and that is in no small
part due to um uh the american rescue
plan so we're absolutely you know
not satisfied or want to accept a
situation where americans are paying
high prices
when they can't afford it i think where
we are in this economy is one where we
have real strength and that positions us
to address real challenges that that
that we that we need to
do
um i want to go back to the child tax
credit december 15 could be that last
check
if bbb is not passed but child tax
credit if it's not passed
what does that do to this child poverty
rate that you have been telling so much
how you slashed it does it stay the same
or do you anticipate a rise with that
well uh we are uh confident that we're
gonna get bill back better passed uh
extending the child tax credit is one of
many reasons why we need to do that and
um we need to do that um as soon as
possible uh and uh and so that's why you
see this administration uh as focused as
we are on working uh with our
congressional uh counterparts to move uh
to move that agenda um there are
uh there are
multiple elements of this bill
where if you look at
costs and you look at how you know
typical household situations the urgency
is very clear this is one
the lack of affordable housing is
another the lack of affordable child
care is another that is not a tomorrow
issue for so many families that are
trying to figure out how to get uh
uh somebody back into the labor market
and so
we're you know that's that's the case
we're making and that's and we're
confident we're gonna get this done
housing can you talk about the price of
new housing as well as existing housing
uh part of the problem they're selling
with
housing parts is new housing prices it
deals with inflation and lumber the cost
of lumber has pushed up the price of
housing and the supply curve issue
how in the short term do you plan to
combat this you can combat that as
you're dealing with the housing issue
and talking about affordable housing
houses to buy right now are up because
of inflation supply chain
supply chain issues yeah so
it it's connected to phil's question you
know the the
um
prices in the in the in the residential
market are are are elevated um but a lot
of that is is a is a supply issue supply
issue is in part connected to
near-term supply chain issues but it is
much deeper and longer term about years
and years in which we've under-invested
in supply compared to the demand that in
the economy for
uh
for housing particularly in certain
regions and geographies the supply chain
challenges that are affecting the inputs
that go into home building um are
similar to the slide chain issues we're
facing overall
but we've tried to take a dedicated
focus in a number of areas so for
example we have an hour's a service
waiver for trucks that move across the
country to be able to
operate additional hours we extended
that to cover
building materials
as well the issue of helping to move
a product through our ports is very
important uh particularly for building
materials that are being imported so um
so you know we're we're focused on the
supply chain issues in general but as
they relate to building materials
wherever they can we're trying to
highlight them all right let's do kayla
and courtney and i'm going to wrap it up
go ahead okay thank you jen thank you
brian um my first question is on russia
the u.s and european allies have pledged
severe harm on russia if it escalates
the situation in ukraine as you in the
white house know the economy is global
it is intertwined especially the energy
market and european consumers are
already paying record costs to keep
their homes this winter so i'm wondering
how the administration is thinking about
mitigating the impact on the u.s economy
with whatever decisions you decide to
take with regard to sanctions
so i will
leave the question of sanctions and the
impact on our european counterparts to
jake and to jen i think they've spoken
to them
and the sort of dynamic involved there
including as it relates to nordstrom
with respect to u.s consumers um
the the
natural gas in particular
is an issue that is is a commodity that
doesn't trade globally and so
uh the decline that i referenced earlier
25
uh decline in natural gas prices since
uh november that's the price of u.s uh
natural gas
which is about i i haven't looked in the
last day but
you know four to five times lower uh
than in europe um and that's uh for a
set of reasons the export constrained
export constraints um but in terms of
the american consumer um uh looking
forward to this winter
there's some
um
positive news in terms of domestic
natural gas and not a lot of um not a
lot of flow through to the issues you're
raising wages just to follow up
domestically i think the average
american would find inflation more
manageable if wages were also going up
and in the last year inflation-adjusted
weekly earnings are down 1.3
so when can americans expect to earn
more money for the work that they're
already doing yeah it's a
it's a a good question in good context
it connects to to uh the uh earlier
question as well so uh if you look at um
if you look at wage growth uh uh it's
important to look at it for a couple of
a couple of lenses the first is where is
that wage growth happening in the income
spectrum and what you're seeing is wage
growth today that is fastest and
strongest in the bottom half of the
income distribution so for working
families that are making
less they're seeing their wages increase
uh more um and in in in many cases
significantly faster than price
increases um so that's uh that's point
one distributionally the second is in
terms of overall household balance
sheets the income that families have and
when you think about a family and
they're them trying to balance their
checkbook or or um the this year the
question is what was my wage increase
and what was the uh what was the support
that i received through checks from the
government uh uh through the child tax
credit and when you take those into
account and look at household income uh
consistent with the data that you just
said the typical family the family you
know at the 50 uh the 50th percentile um
has actually seen their household income
increase even accounting for price
increases obviously as we move forward
in this recovery what we want to see is
we want to see a strong labor market
recovery we want to see wage
increases uh particularly for those at
the bottom and we want to see you know a
balancing out here um prices that's the
scenario that we're all trying to work
toward
bernie last one can you give an update
on the competition council that you're
sharing it's something i didn't hear you
mentioned in the context of all this
you said is something that's what
louder the competition council you never
mentioned it in all of this can you talk
about some of the accomplishments of
that council and what you all are
working on right now sure sure i'm
excited for the interest um and we will
have
uh
i don't mean that i mean that sincerely
no
uh i mean that sincerely uh
so uh uh
and we will be um we'll be convening the
full council around the end of the year
um and so uh uh look out for that um
uh
it's uh it's um i can talk about some of
the specifics but i will say that
actually you know it's it's consistent
with a general philosophy that does
interact with a lot of the things that
we're discussing here which is that the
president's the core directive in the in
in the executive order was to pursue
pro-competition policies
across uh the federal government across
agencies and use antitrust
statutes enforce them robustly
across agencies as well and so this
intersects with a number of issues that
we've discussed i would note positively
that the um that the house this week
passed a bill on uh increasing
competition in ocean uh uh shipping uh
uh uh which is something that we um
encouraged uh um as part of that uh
executive order but more more you know
more directly
you take uh an issue like the
railroads um and the you know lack of
competition in that sector well that
affects this question of how do we
unstick bottlenecks if there's not
sufficient competition among among rail
lines we talk about food prices and i
think the last time i was here i was
with secretary vilsack
when you look at most of the um the
increase in food costs you can isolate a
significant portion of that to
meat
beef pork and chicken in particular
those are very concentrated industries
where a small number of meat processors
control
the
the industry and so what you've seen is
prices for the the farmers uh go up
prices for consumers go up um and uh um
and uh and profits for the processing uh
uh companies in the middle um go up and
that's an issue of concern and one that
we have focused on both from an
antitrust perspective but also investing
in helping competitors get into that
market uh in fact today we're making 500
million dollars available to small
meat processors to try to increase
competition in that space so be happy to
follow up and give you a full slate of
where we are on the there were for those
of you who are paying attention there
were 72 specific uh actions in that
executive order you're tracking against
all of them
um
but uh but i will spare the rest of you
uh and we'll be happy to follow all
right
thank you everyone so much thank you
it definitely got much longer than i
promised so we want him to come back um
all right so i only have one item for
all of you at the top as i think all of
you saw this morning or many of you saw
this morning the president opened the
summit for democracy and announced the
presidential initiative for democratic
renewal a landmark set of policy and
foreign assistance initiatives to defend
and bolster democracy human rights and
the fight against corruption the
initiative represents a significant
targeted expansion of u.s government
efforts to defend sustain and grow
democratic resilience with like-minded
governmental and non-governmental
partners in the coming year the united
states is planning to provide up to
424.4 million dollars toward the
initiative and these efforts will center
on five areas of war crucial to the
functioning of transparent accountable
governance including supporting free and
independent media fighting corruption
bolstering democratic reformers
advancing technology for democracy
defending free and fair elections and
political processes i know we'll also
have a call this afternoon i'm not sure
exactly the timing uh to give you more
uh information on the deliverables from
this as well colleen why don't you kick
us off or continue our journey here
together thank you um do you have an
update for us on the president's call
with zelenski
and um another one just sort of related
sort of um there were a couple of
reports last night about a potential
financial threat or military action
um to iran in regards to the faltering
nuclear talks i wonder if you have a
comment or update on that sure let me
start with the first when i came out
here the president was still on the call
so our plan was to provide a written
readout to all of you which you should
be getting as soon as it's complete or
following the briefing whenever it's
ready but i will uh highlight for you
that the president's intention going
into this call was to provide an update
for president zielinski on his call with
president putin and underscore our
support for ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity uh as secretary
blanken did when he spoke with president
zielinski earlier this week so this is a
follow-on to that call uh president ryan
is also intending to was intending to
discuss his deep concerns with russia's
build-up on ukraine's borders and his
commitment to respond with strong
measures in the event of a russian
military escalation we've engaged
closely with the ukrainians throughout
this process at a range of levels and
have been in daily contact with senior
officials in the ukrainian government so
clearly that is a component of it i'd
also note i think as many of you saw
that president also provided an update
to the b9 eastern flank countries with a
personal readout of his call with
president putin uh to hear their
perspectives on the current social
security situation and underscore our
commitment to transatlantic security
into uh our nato allies that are in its
with our nato laws as sacred and also to
continue to stay in close coordination
on the but we will get you um a readout
as soon as that is complete uh on the
iran question that you also posed second
i do have an update for you uh as we've
said many times from this podium and
elsewhere in the government president
biden is committed to ensuring iran
never acquires a nuclear weapon and
believes diplomacy in coordination with
allies and regional partners is the best
path to achieve that goal we delete
believe a diplomatic resolution offers
the best best path to avoiding a nuclear
crisis
however given the ongoing advances in
iran's nuclear program the president has
asked his team to be prepared in the
event that diplomacy fails and we must
turn to other options and that requires
preparations we have made clear to iran
that the only path out of sanctions is
through nuclear compliance we have kept
all the sanctions that we inherited in
place and we have consistently enforced
sanctions all while also presenting the
clear path of their removal if diplomacy
cannot get on track soon and if iran's
nuclear program continues to accelerate
then we will have no choice but to take
additional measures to further restrict
iran's revenue producing sectors well
i'm not going to get into additional
specifics on that front i can provide
you a little update on some of the
coordination that we're doing on the
international on and into the
international front a senior treasury
official will lead a treasury state
delegation to the uae next week to talk
about sanctions compliance the
delegation which will be led by ofac
director andrea gaki will focus on
engagements with the private sector and
key uae government officials to discuss
our understanding of the companies and
financial institutions that facilitate
non-compliant iranian commerce that runs
through or touches the uae this trip
follows a range of conversations that
our national security adviser jake
sullivan and brett mcgurk had in october
that obviously rob malley and brett
mcgurk had in november and deputy
treasury secretary adayama also had in
november uh and this is uh part of our
uh extended outreach to our partners
around the world to ensure that we are
preparing for a range of contingencies
so the timeline on you know how long
the diplomacy is going to continue
before
actions i'm not going to present a
deadline today but what i can tell you
is that
we have presented a diplomatic path
forward uh that path is still open uh
but based on the outcome of the last
round of talks and the ongoing
advancements in iran's nuclear
facilities we are laying the path for uh
the groundwork for another path entirely
so it's just meant to be preparations
the president said he'd hope to announce
by tomorrow meetings between russia and
nato allies about russia's concerns
do you have any update on that meeting
and who may be attending i i think what
the president was referring to is a a
range of uh discussions and engagements
that we're continuing to have today the
b9 as an example of that obviously there
are a number of nato partners involved
there and of course we will well i have
nothing to preview at this point the
president two presidents asked their
teams to follow up and we expect that to
continue as well so it was not meant to
be an indication of a deal cut
concessions made any formal format or
anything along those lines more about
the commitment to ongoing engagement and
you've said you know you don't know what
vladimir putin's next move is here it's
not clear yet whether he's made up his
mind whether or not uh to invade ukraine
but uh
just the russian president said the
situation in southeast ukraine resembles
genocide that was how he described it is
that something that you would view as a
rhetorical escalation
uh well the russians are known for their
rhetorical escalations as they are also
known for their
ways of
of providing misinformation around the
world and within eastern flank countries
so i think we have to take their own
efforts to communicate to their public
with a grain of salt what we know is
that
the aggression here is on the russian
side the military buildup is on the
russian side uh there's a path a
diplomatic path forward uh the part of
the president's objective our
president's objective and having the
call was to convey that clearly that
certainly is our preference but also to
convey clearly that there would be
consequences they would be significant
and severe and we're going to coordinate
with our european partners on that so i
would unfortunately as i've said before
not a spokesperson for the kremlin and i
would take uh their their words with a
little bit of a grain of salt go ahead
thank you just a quick question on um
ukraine's asked to become a member of
the nato uh alliance and they've
put that out for several years it's been
out there but really has there hasn't
been any decision on that what is the
united states position on that issue i
mean does that does the president
generally support the enlargement of
nato or does he does he want uh the
alliance to add new members what is his
position well in india the president has
spoken to this in the past and obviously
there are requirements that any country
which the president certainly supports
any country aspiring to join security
alliances nato and others as well and he
supportly
supports
the aspiration of ukraine there are
certain requirements that they would
need to meet uh on a range of issues
including corruption and other topics
and it's obviously up to nato partner
countries and nato uh the alliance to
determine uh what the path forward looks
like as the sort of the biggest member
of the alliance largest member of the
alliance what is the u.s telling nato on
this issue specifically and is the
president perhaps offering any
assurances to uh president zolensky
today as he speaks to him on this issue
no the president's message has been
clear there are there he certainly
supports uh the aspiration of ukraine as
he supports the aspiration of a range of
countries again to join security
alliances around the world there are
certain requirements that need to be met
those are well known and the united
states as a member of nato supports that
path
sorry a quick question on the senate
passage of the republican bill um
yesterday to overturn president biden's
vaccine mandate for private employers
are you concerned that given sort of the
democratic support that that um a bill
actually was able to get are you
concerned that it perhaps uh will
actually uh be able to you know interest
some centrist house democrats to maybe
join in and you know and and secure a
vote on that i understand the white
house has said that you know you will be
until the resolution if it lands on the
president's desk well i think what's
most important for people to know out
there and to understand is the reason
why the president proposed uh these
requirements which include not just a
vaccine requirement but also a testing
option testing once a week which we feel
and i think the american people feel is
quite reasonable in order to keep
workplaces safe keep school safe keep a
store safe where people are out there
christmas shopping and holiday shopping
safe uh we also know that it's something
it's steps that economists support it's
steps that 60 of businesses have already
put in place so again we're hopeful that
this doesn't come to the president's
desk uh i can't make a prediction of
that i'd leave that to the vote counters
or the whip counters uh in in the house
but if it comes to his desk he will veto
it
good thanks jen um apart from whatever
president zolensky might have asked the
president for today can you clarify
what ukraine has formally requested
of the u.s as they prepare for any
potential invasion have they requested
support for air and naval defense or
electronic
warfare as an example well we're not
going to get into
specifics of private requests made
through diplomatic and defense channels
from the ukrainian government if they
want to speak to that they certainly can
speak to that
i would note that there were requests
there have been requests made over the
course of time and the united states has
provided uh over the course of some time
now i guess uh 400 billion i believe
this is correct 400 million sorry
billion would be a lot uh 400 million
dollars in security assistance that
we've committed uh to ukraine this year
as a part of our efforts to support
their sovereignty and territorial
integrity and that includes 60 million
dollars of security assistance that we
announced during the president's uh
visit in september which we're still
providing we're still delivering to the
ukrainians so in terms of their specific
requests what they want to convey
privately if they want to convey that
publicly that is certainly their
prerogative but we would not do that on
their behalf and the head of ukraine's
military intelligence service is quoted
in the new york times saying there are
not sufficient military resources for
repelling a full-scale attack by russia
if it begins without the support of
western forces
has ukraine
expressed a similar sentiment to the
administration and do you have a
response
again i'm not going to get into private
diplomatic conversations but i will
convey to you and what the president
would convey has conveyed i'm sure is
conveying directly to uh president
zielinski our objective is to
make clear uh this significant and
severe economic consequences if russia
were to invade ukraine not just from us
but from the global community obviously
it's up to president putin to decide uh
how he's going to respond to that what
steps he may or may not take as it
relates to that but i think what the uh
public should see clearly whether it's
the ukrainian republic or the global
public is that the united states is
standing up for what we believe are
democratic values for the territorial uh
the sovereignty of ukraine and our
objective is to prevent that from
happening
based on conversations pfizer has had
with the administration should americans
be mentally preparing for
a fourth shot
i would point you really to what the cdc
and our health and medical experts have
conveyed and they will continue to
evaluate and assess what is needed for
the american people and to keep people
safe but i don't want to get ahead of
their reviews of data go ahead jackie
thanks jen um on vaccines
amtrak which we know is near and dear to
the president's heart
announced that they will
potentially have to cut some
long-distance routes
because they don't have enough employees
to operate when the federal mandate
takes effect and that's despite that
reporting on the hill today that 94 of
their employees are vaccinated overall
amtrak got 66 billion dollars from the
infrastructure deal now they're talking
about having to make cuts is this policy
undermining the president's own
legislation
well first i would say you touched on
this jackie but it's great news that 94
of amtrak's workforce is vaccinated that
is an enormous percentage of their
workforce to state the obvious they also
still have
about a month before the deadline for
federal contractors on january 4th or at
least a couple of weeks four weeks
approximately
what we what we have conveyed to
employers is that post-deadline we
expect employers will follow their
standard hr process that means if for
employees not in compliance they'll go
through education counseling
accommodations and enforcement that
would be what the process would be to
play out but of course uh these
requirements uh we don't expect these
requirements will cause disruptions to
sources that people depend on there's
some time to implement it uh we're of
course working with all federal
contractors and and federal employees
and and uh
parts of the federal government uh to
implement this moving forward on ukraine
there are some reports that the us is
pressuring ukraine to seed land to
russia as a way to deter them from
invading is that true no that's
absolutely false
thank you staying on
russian troops ukraine still amassed
along the border
do you have any indication at this point
that the president's strategy is working
well first i think it's going to be up
to president putin to make a decision
about uh whether he is going to invade
ukraine uh uh up in in in and send a
message to the global community that he
does not respect the territorial
integrity of a country when the united
states our european partners are sending
a clear message that there will be
significant economic consequences severe
economic consequences beyond as jake
sullivan said the other day what we have
seen in 2014 uh so at this point
obviously you would know if they have
made the decision to invade they have
not
uh but again it's it's the poland is in
his court
we know that ukraine some lawmakers on
capitol hill said that they want more
military equipment now i know we don't
have a readout yet it's a call but are
there any discussions about potentially
sending that equipment now and not
waiting until there's further invasion
well there is equipment that we're
continuing to provide uh that is a
follow-up from uh the president
zalensky's meeting with president biden
back in september so that is something
they're continuing to receive and of
course there are a range of uh options
under consideration uh but nothing i can
preview at this point
they're basically saying yes that is the
case but given this current situation
they actually won absolutely i
understand that and they've conveyed
that publicly i don't have anything to
preview at this point uh but certainly
we have been a strong supporter of not
only the sovereignty of ukraine but also
through security assistance and the
president has a long record of that
one just domestically on the child tax
credit and really just following up on
the questions that april was asking yeah
are there any discussions about
potentially pulling that piece out of
buildback better and passing it
unilaterally as a standalone bill if
bill back better doesn't pass by
christmas so that there isn't a lapse
well i think april i don't know where
she went okay there she is i was
pointing to her in the ether there um
april raised an important point here
which is that december 15th would be the
last uh child check
from the child tax credit uh because it
would expire january 1st uh one of the
reasons that we have been pressing for
the passing of
the bill back better is because there
are key components of this package that
would lower costs for american families
early next year so when we talk about
inflation and we talk about costs and
how they're impacting families budgets
that's why we leader schumer and others
have been pressing so hard to move this
forward in terms of the mechanics of
legislative vehicles i'd really point
you to the senate on that uh but again
uh you know that is a timeline uh and
that is something that we are well aware
of and to go back to a camera who asked
the question before maybe april maybe
jackie i'm not sure uh it is true that
in part because of the child tax credit
we cut child poverty in half
i'm not an economist i can check and see
if there's more predictions of what the
impact of the lack of existence of that
would be but that sends a clear message
about the impact that has had on low
income families on families who are
struggling to put food on the table and
it's been a pivotal
contributor to our our success in doing
that go ahead thanks i just want to
circle back the president's comments
yesterday about nato allies
he said that he hoped by friday he would
be able to announce meetings at a higher
level not just with us but with at least
four of our major nato allies and russia
to discuss the future of russia's
concerns relative to nato writ large
are these meetings conversations not
happening and if not what was he talking
about exactly well he has a call with
the b9 uh this afternoon that's
something that includes a number of nato
allies and of course we are in touch
every single day with a number of nato
allies and partners and as i noted a
little bit earlier uh when he when he
had the conversation with president
putin they discussed and agreed to have
their teams follow up in ongoing
discussions and engagements in terms of
any other format or forum uh there's no
current mechanism for that um but right
now our focus is on engaging with the
europeans many of our nato allies doing
that at a very high level as the
president referenced and also following
up as was discussed in his call with
president expect some kind of
announcement tomorrow about some sort of
conversation with
the entities he's talking about about
accommodations not one that i have to
predict at this point in time go ahead
oh go ahead go ahead captain but um the
president uh today spoke about global
press freedom during the summit yeah
just wondering if he's going to commit
to holding a year-end press conference
well one i i would say that global press
freedom uh is something that he uh feels
is important to stand up for not just
here but when he is uh traveling around
the world and ensuring that your
colleagues around the world uh who are
dealing with circumstances where uh they
don't they are put in jail uh they don't
have access to any officials uh they are
restricted from covering uh
uh global events human rights abuses
around the world uh not that what you
don't all do isn't very challenging i'm
not suggesting that but there are a lot
of circumstances around the world that i
think even go beyond go beyond
i would say the president answers
questions multiple times a week
i think he's done it already several
times this week i don't have a formal
press conference with embroidered
cushions to predict for you at this
point in time but i can assure you that
he will take your questions many many
times before the end of the year and he
looks forward absolutely to doing that
go ahead josh
can i just ask quickly on wrong
folks you're preparing are there
particular sectors that these sanctions
would be aimed at or can you give us any
more detail about what happens
sure certainly understand your question
josh i think part of the effort of our
uh ofac director in going oversea going
to the uae to have these discussions is
to
have these discussions at that level
about the range of sectors and options
but i don't have anything else to
preview at this point in time that
existing restrictions are being violated
with regards to this trip when people
are finding a way around existing uh
we're talking about we have kept the
sanctions in place we're talking about
additional steps should they be needed
obviously a diplomatic path forward and
having a constructive dialogue through
the p5 plus one format is our objective
but we're preparing a range of options
in addition to what we have in place
that's part of our discussions and this
is part of the the our ofac director's
trip is building on uh conversations uh
that brett mcgurk that jake sullivan and
others have been having in europe as
well just a quick question on um just
real quick questions on the the
democracy summit you mentioned the 424
million dollars you have a sense how
much of that is already appropriated
versus how much would need to be
approved from congress uh let me check
scott it's a really good question i
don't have that in front of me but i
will check for you and i'll get that
around to all of you
go ahead ashley two quick questions on
ukraine one why did president biden
immediately call top u.s allies right
after speaking with president putin and
waited two days to call president
zielinski
uh he was traveling yesterday i think as
you all know and he was looking forward
to having a good uh lengthy call with
president zielinski today which i expect
he will do i would note that we also
followed up with ukrainian counterparts
at a lower level than the president uh
so it was just a matter of scheduling
and getting it all in the books
the president also said that uh combat
troops on the ground in ukraine are
currently off the table can you give us
a sense of what would change that
calculation when they would be back on
the table that's not currently part of
our discussion or part of our policy
calculations so
i don't have anything to predict on that
front
thank you uh upon afghanistan um there's
uh in recent days some parolees or
people seeking parole have started to be
denied
who are looking to flee from afghanistan
i understand this system has been
flooded with i think roughly 30 000
applications but some of the lawyers for
those parole laser applicants have said
that the documentation requirement
including specifying an address or a
specific threat given that it might have
been 10 years ago or their home might
have been destroyed
is a pretty high standard is the
president currently satisfied with this
system of humanitarian parole or is
there any thought lobbying congress for
another special parole program well
here here's what we're doing i know you
didn't exactly ask me this and you
follow this closely but for others um
through operation allies welcome we're
proud to have welcomed more than 74 000
afghans to the united states and have
received funding from congress to accept
up to 95 000 through operation allies
welcome through the current fiscal year
so obviously what we're doing now is
continuing to process through through a
vetting process and through and there
are requirements of that of course as
there should be uh that's in addition to
afghans who are admitted through the u.s
refugee admission program and other
pathways you touched on this all in a
little bit but the infrastructure to
support refugee resettlement was
decimated by the prior administration
we've been working hard to rebuild that
capacity i would say the success we've
had to date of welcoming that number of
people is a reflection of the fact that
we've made some progress in that regard
and right now dhs is processing
applications for afghan nationals
located outside of the united states who
are seeking humanitarian reform based on
urgent humanitarian need or significant
public benefit reason there are going to
be requirements of course through any of
these systems as there should be as we
consider welcoming people back in we're
continuing to uh put in more resources
so that we can process more people uh
and continuing to uh try to take ever do
everything we do can can do everything
we can i should say sorry to handle the
surge in interest and in cases uh but
there will be people who don't meet the
requirements who aren't going to be able
to come to the united states and we just
want to be very clear and transparent
about that as well
with the with the democracy summit again
uh at a cnn town hall the president was
asked about voting rights police reform
he said that he had been so focused on
buildback veteran infrastructure but
that he was going to move on to that
indicated you move on to that now that
we are moving you know you've had some
progress with that legislation is there
any update towards whether he would be
more open to a filibuster carve out or
just what exactly is he doing when it
comes to those two legislative measures
given the summit going on sure well one
i would say as the president as you
heard the president say uh you know
having a summit like this is an
opportunity to discuss how we can all
improve our democracies protect uh
democracy around the world and do that
in coordination with not just leaders
but civil society actors private sector
etcetera that's the purpose of this
summit there are dozens of white house
staff working every single day on voting
rights and this priority it's
fundamental to upholding the rule of law
you've heard the president talk about
this many times since he took office he
signed a historic executive order in
march we've worked to double the voting
rights staff in the civil rights
division he's appointed the vice
president at her request to lead this
effort there are discussions as you know
in congress among a range of leaders
about how to continue to move this
forward and we are eager active
participants of those discussions i
don't have anything more in terms of
views or his steps on the legislative
process at this point
don't have any updates today okay i
gotta i gotta i gotta wrap in a second
let me go to afp go ahead go ahead thank
you very much
go ahead you've got it thank you one on
russia or one one of ukraine yeah and
one in china from it
um can you tell us a bit more about
president biden's how present by the
views
putin's central argument um which seems
to boil down to
they don't want ukraine made eventually
nato b also not have any
us offensive weapons
um or nato offensive weapons in ukraine
so when president biden referred to
looking for accommodations
is he talking about cutting some sort of
deal with cruz and about we won't do
this if you don't do that let me be very
clear president biden told president
putin in their call that one nation
can't force another nation to change its
border one nation cannot tell another to
change its politics and nations can't
tell others who they can work with we've
consistently expressed support for the
principle that every country has the
sovereign right to make its own
decisions with respect to its security
that is written into the underlying
principle of the alliance and that
remains u.s policy today and will remain
u.s policy in the future as you know
nato is a defensive alliance
and they don't have aggressive intent
toward russia they've conveyed that
leaders of nato have conveyed that every
step we have taken is to put in place
the protective measures needed to defend
our allies so that just to be clear
about where the president stands that is
what he conveyed
a
directly
to
president
china yes uh the olympics
um would uh president bannon like
european allies to join this uh
diplomatic boycott um initiative is he
just disappointed in french
very publicly not doing so and and just
more generally uh you know if you're
going to talk about genocide in a
country which is you know right right
there in the statement
is playing sports at all a kind of a
reasonable thing to be doing um why stop
the diplomatic boycott
well well first i would say this is the
decision we made the united states made
the united states has been a leader in
holding
china accountable as it relates to human
rights abuses
the what we've seen in xinjiang which
again the president and we have referred
to as a genocide and we have taken steps
at the global level to lead this effort
to put accountability measures in place
as it relates to the olympics
we made a decision the president made a
decision that we cannot continue with
business as usual that not sending a
diplomatic delegation was making that
clear not just to china but to the
global community there are others who
have followed that uh same pattern of
taking that step as well we leave it to
other countries to make their own
decision i'm not going to express
support disappointment or anything like
that from here they will make their own
decision and i will also just paraphrase
and i wish i had the quote in front of
me senator romney uh where he said uh
then his quote was better than this so
i'm a paraphrasing in here but that uh
we cannot leave global diplomacy on the
shoulders of athletes who have been
training their whole lives to compete in
the olympics if you look back at 1980
and there was a boycott all of those
people who trained for the olympics uh
it was left on their shoulders uh young
athletes who have been training their
whole lives we are sending a very clear
message about our view on human rights
but we made the decision not to leave
that on the shoulders of athletes uh let
me just go to raquel and then we gotta
wreck up raquel go ahead rico
can we let her go
simon simon
simon simon i'm trying to answer your
question and then i'm gonna go to raquel
okay
can i say one thing raquel and that'll
go to you simon we're evaluating every
single day we don't want these to be
permanent measures and and it is
something that the president is getting
updates from his kova team every single
day on so my question is the the omegran
variant is now in 57 countries the who
issued a statement today and said that
africa has 46 percent of the nearly 1
000 cases globally but 70 almost 70
countries in the world have imposed
travel ban on only black african nation
and the us is among the countries that
have imposed sanctions on only eight
african nations when divide when the
variant is in 57 countries why don't you
just lift it or impose function on all
the countries that have it what will you
say to those who believe that this is a
racist ban that targets only african and
black african nations simon i would
convey to you that is absolutely not the
intention that is not our policy this
was a recommendation of the health and
medical experts because there were a
large number of cases south africa and
they made a decision early on out of an
abundance of caution and to protect the
american people to slow the threat of
the variant this is not meant to be
permanent it's not meant to be a
punishment and we are evaluating every
single day decisions on whether to when
to lift these restrictions go ahead
recall thank you so much thank you
here today in the white house what is
the white house assessment so far from
what you guys are hearing uh or
from world leaders and the commitment
they're making and also what commitments
would president biden like to see from
brazil and other countries experience
right now forms of democratic uh
backsliding what is uh president biden
expecting to hear from president
bolsonaro tomorrow well i would say
first that the the president convened
the summit uh in order to
have a forum at a global level
to discuss publicly but also privately
and he convened a private discussion
with leaders this morning to engage
listen and speak honestly about the
challenges and opportunities facing
democratic governments and how
democracies can deliver for their
citizens and part of this is an
opportunity as i noted in my opening to
stand up for uh the freedom of speech
the freedom of press uh for ensuring
that as a global community we are
lifting up democratic societies we are
fighting corruption we are bolstering
democratic reforms and the united states
wants to be a country that leads by
example um and builds and repairs from
the damage done for four years thank you
so much everyone i appreciate you have a
good day
yes
you